翻訳: Syunsuke Yoshikawa
校正: Kumika Moore
この写真 見て頂けますか？
私の息子といとこたちの写真です
この頃は可愛かったんですよ
将来どんな大人になるのかなって
楽しみにしていた頃でした
左端のちょっとお地蔵様にも似ているのが
私の次男です
この次男 20年経って飲食店を任されて
やりがいを持って仕事を頑張っていました
その息子がある日 こうつぶやきました
「うつ病かもしれない」
私は冷静を装っていましたが
心の中は焦っていて
「えっ 仕事楽しいって言ってたじゃない」
「私 前向きで元気なイメージで
コーチングのインストラクターしているのに
どうしたらいいの？」
辛そうにしている息子よりも
自分の立場や世間体で頭がいっぱいでした
情けない母親ですよね
その後 息子は仕事に行けなくなって
「ひきこもり」という状態になりました
大人の「ひきこもり」
実は大勢いることをご存知ですか？
仕事に行けなくて
家族以外の人との交流もほとんどしないで
過ごしている人たちです
私たちはそういう人が
実際にどれぐらいいるのか
地元の方や学生さんに
アンケート調査をしました
その結果
6.4% 15人に１人
大人の「ひきこもり」の方がいると
分かりました
年齢も様々で
15歳から62歳まで
いらっしゃいました
そして日本だけじゃなく
世界中に「ひきこもり」の人はいます
これは徐々に問題になってきています
「ひきこもり」の人への主なサポートは
３つあります
１つはカウンセリングでお悩みを聞きます
２つ目は楽しめる場の提供
みんなで話をしようとか
ゲームをやろうというもの
３つ目は外へ連れ出そうというサポート
だから私も
ある時は「話を聞かせてよ」と近寄ったり
ある時は旅行や買い物に誘ったりして
何とか早く元のように
笑って仕事に行ってほしくて
努力してきました
朝から大きな声で怒鳴ったりもしました
でも息子は「うーん」と言ったきり
全く動きませんでした
私は無力感に襲われました
疲れちゃったんです
一体 何のためにやってきたんだろう？
「息子のために」って
肩肘張って頑張って頑張って
疲れちゃって
やっと気づきました
私は息子に勝手な期待をしていたんですよね
前向きに生きてほしい
仕事を楽しんでほしい
でも息子は仕事頑張りすぎて 苦しくなって
前が見えなくなってしまってたんです
私の世間体や立場のためじゃなくて
息子が何を求めているのか
それを最初に考える必要があったんですよね
そこまで分かるのに５年掛かりました
これまでの３つのサポートに
効果が無いわけではなくて
私のようにとても時間が掛かります
それよりも何を求めているのか
それを提供することができれば
短期間で社会復帰できるんじゃないのかな？
で 息子に実際に試してみたら
すんなりと動きました
だったら息子以外の「ひきこもり」の人にも
役に立つんじゃないのかな
て考えて活動を始めました
その方法はいたってシンプルです
今のままでもできる仕事をつなぐこと
外に出られなくても 人と話をしなくても
できる仕事をやってもらっています
例えば手書きのアンケートをデータ入力する
これだったら連絡もメールでできますし
自宅で十分できます
左側の方は不安障害という心の病気で
今「Excel」を
教えてもらってるところです
教えているのは
脳性まひで車いすを使っている女性です
次の写真は着物をリフォームする方のために
縫ってある糸をほどいているところです
この彼女も不安障害です
細かい作業ですけど
丁寧にやってくれています
他にも靴磨きやポスティング
似顔絵やイラストを描く
お庭の草取りや犬の散歩といった
作業もあります
作業をした結果として代金をお支払いします
自分のやった結果で得られるお金
自分の力で稼いだお金
これは何よりも自信を生みます
私たちは悩みを聞きません
なぜだと思いますか？
悩みを解決するよりも
小さな事でもいいから行動すること
現実を少しでも変えること
これを優先しています
家の中や１人で簡単にできる
今のままでもできる仕事
これなんです
この方法のさらに面白いところは
ここからです
彼らは自分からどんどん変化していくんです
例えばこんな事がありました
ポスティングやホームページの英訳を
お願いしていた男性は
「そろそろ勤めに出たい」と自分から言って
今は私の知り合いの会社で
バイトをしています
「仕事から帰ってくると
『体力をつける』と言って
ランニングを始めたんですよ」って
お母さんから内緒で聞きました
別のケースでは
統合失調症という病気を持ちながら
ポスティングの仕事を始めた男性の
妹さんから
「日奈さん うちの兄とすれ違った時に
『お疲れ』って 手を振ってきたんですよ
こんなこと何十年ぶりだったかな」
という声をいただきました
この男性も今は就職をして
憧れだった一人暮らしをしています
みんな自分から動き始めてるんです
でも「ひきこもり」の人って
「本当に働く気があるの？」って
思いませんか？
私もよく聞かれます
もし「意欲がない」とするなら
「ひきこもり」は彼らが望んだ状態なので
幸せな顔をしているはずですよね？
でもそんな顔はしていません
口では「もう仕事をしたくない」と
言っていても
本当は「誰かの役に立ちたい」という想いを
心の奥に持っています
私はその「役に立ちたい」という想いを
彼らが持っていることを信じています
「こういう仕事ありますよ
やりませんか？」って話をするんですが
早い人で その時に
「やります」と返事がきます
慎重な方でも２、３ヶ月後ぐらいには
仕事を始めています
本人に会って話ができると
８割の方が仕事を始めています
でもそんな彼らの
「役に立ちたい」という想いを
邪魔するものがあるんですよね
それは「ひきこもり」
「ひきこもり」というと
「怠けてる」「甘えてる」
「働く気がない」という
イメージじゃないですか？
では 家にいて人とあんまり話もしないけど
家で仕事をする人のことを
皆さん何と呼びますか？
「在宅ワーカー」って呼びますよね？
「在宅ワーカー」 いかがでしょうか？
何か可能性 感じませんか？
今まで彼らに付けられていた名前は
「ひきこもり」
それを「在宅ワーカー」と変えると
彼らの「役に立ちたい」という想いに
ぴったり合った呼び方になります
そう呼ぶことで私たちも
彼らを仕事ができる人と
捉えられるようにもなりますよね？
だからこれからは「ひきこもり」ではなくて
「在宅ワーカー」と彼らを呼んでみませんか？
そして今のままでもできる仕事を
彼らに頼んでみませんか？
私の息子も靴磨きの仕事をやり始めました
今では在宅ワークを始めようという人たちの
お兄さん役としてお世話をしています
私もこの活動を始めてから
親子の会話が増えてきました
これが一番嬉しかったかも
私はこれまでたっくさんの
「ひきこもり」と呼ばれてきた
「在宅ワーカー」に会ってきました
彼らが一歩を踏み出す時
そこには共通するポイントがありました
それは周りの方の意識が変わった時です
もしも「ひきこもり」という
問題を解決したいなら
十分苦しんでいる彼らに
変わらせるんじゃないんです
変わるのは
変わってほしいと願う
私たちなんです
ありがとうございました
（拍手）